تناولنا من ايام المفاوضات الجاريه بين
فريق ترامب وشركه متاب بخصوص اعاده تفعيل
حسابات واللي من خلالها طالب فيها محامي
ترامب بالنيابه عنه مساء اعاده تفعيل
حسابات الرئيس الامريكي السابق على فيسبوك
وانستغرام وكمان طالب اجتماع فوري للشركه
لمناقشه الطلب واتخاذ قرار عوده ترامب
للمنصه من بعد حضور دام عامين من بعد
احداث الكعبه في 20 21 واللي انحضر بعضها
ترامب من على اغلب المنصات الجديد اليوم
انه شركه متى اتخذت قرارها ونشرت مذكره عن
وانت بانهاء تعليق حسابات ترامب باسوار
حمايه جديده اللي يرجع تكرار الجرائم اما
مضمونها فقالت الشركه ان هم لا يريد انه
يعيق طريق النقاش المفتوح
والديمقراطي وخصوصا عند المجتمعات اللي
بتشهد انتخابات ديمقراطيه مثل امريكا وانه
لازم يكون الجمهور قادر انه يسمع اللي
بيقولوه السياسيين ايش ما كان علشان
يقدروا ياخذوا القرارات الصح وقت
الانتخابات وانه تعليق حسابات ترامب انتهى
ولكن انه راح يخضع لمعايير وقوانين متى
مثلوا مثل اي مستخدم اخر وراح يكون في
عقوبات مشدده في حال تكرار اللي صار في 21
او في سنه 21 وكان رئيس مثل الشؤون
العالميه كمان غرد وقال انه انتهى قرار
تعليق حسابات ترامب وانه الحظر اللي كان
في 20 21 راح وانه تقييم الظروف الحاليه
استنادا لسياسه اداره الازمات الخاصه فيهم
وامه ترامب فكانت تردد فعلك العاده بحساب
الخساره والربح واكيد هو شايف انه عدم
وجوده في ايمن خساره فكتب على منصه السوشي
لانه فيسبوك خسر مليارات الدولارات من
قيمته من وقت ما تم حظر الرئيس المفضل في
امريكا وطبعا بالرئيس المفضل ترامب هنا
بيقص نفسه ولازم هذا الشيء ما يتكرر ثاني
مع اي رئيس خلال ولايه او اي شخص ما
بيستحق العقاب بحسب كلام ترامب وشكر منصه
تروت سوشيال اللي كان اطلقها من بعد الحظر
على المهمه اللي قامت فيها في الفتره
الماضيه وقال انه بتشهد نمو مذهل ومستقبل
غير محدود اما عن عوده ترامب لمنصت تويتر
اللي كان الون ماسك شال الحظر عنه فيها من
19 نوفمبر زي ما بتتذكر ومشاهدينا ما في
اي تعليق بهذا الخصوص وحتى الان ترامب لم
يستخدم هذا الحساب ولم يغرد حتى الان طيب
للمزيد عن عوده حسابات ترامب الى من
الصلاه التواصل نتحدث مع الكاتب والباحث
السياسي بشار جرار اللي بينضم لنا هاتفيه
معنا هل نعتبر عوده الحسابات بعد في متى
بعد عوده حسابات او حساب ترامب في تويتر
انتصار لترامب
ساره نقول العوده يعني من حيث المتابعه
كمشاهدين على الاقل وليس بالضروره متخزي
مواقف سياسيه مع ترامب او ضد العوده الى
ان النقاش سيكون ممتع اكثر تكون سريع اكثر
وخاصه في هذا التوقيت الحساس هذا توقيت
فيها فضائح سياسيه بامتياز في المشهد
السياسي الامريكيين لاحظ قضيه الوثائق
المسربه المعايير المزدوجه التي طرحها
الاعلام
كان عنده همم وجدوا لديه وسائق يعني انه
سريه للغايه موجوده لديه هذه الوثائق كان
لازم تسلم للبيت الابيض لكن في نفس الوقت
الان اتضح انه عنده كمان هو وثائق ايضا
سريه موجوده في بيته يعني
نعم هو فقط ليس في كراج منزله في داروه
وليس فقط ابان خدمته كنائب للرئيس وانما
ايضا عندما كانسر عضو في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي وهذا هذه فضيحه مركبه بحد ذاتها
لانه ليس من صلاحيات على الاطلاق
التعامل مع هذه الوثائق السريه خارج
القاعه في داخل
فهذه القضيه ايضا اخرى
فانت الان بتقول انه بيحدث الامر مع بيضه
ما بنشوف نفس المعايير يعني مطبقه لا
يهاجم بيضا بنفس الحجم يعني
صحيح والاعلام عن المشكله الكبرى هي
الاعلام كيف تعامل الاعلام الامريكي سواء
التقليدي او الجديد اللي هو السوشيال
ميديا في هذه الفضاء المتتاليه حتى الان
نائب الرئيس الامريكي يعني بكل السجالات
اللي كانت بينه وبين الرئيس ترامب واللي
لها علاقه في قضيه حظر التمر
في الانتخابات السابقه ايضا وقع في نفس
المقبض
وتم العثور عليها في في منزله المساله
الان هو هذه العوده
يزلها
ويتخذ القرار بشانها الرئيس السابق
من معايير سياسيه وتجاريه ايضا من ناحيه
الربحيه
هذه مساله تعليم استثمار وليس فقط كمنظر
اعلامي بالتالي تجدين الفارق كيف يتعامل
مع موضوع العوده لتويتر وهو ايضا كانت له
بعض الاراء
المارسك همم كيفيه اتخاذ القرارات يعني
التغيير وهو يحاول ان يلقي على مسافه بينه
وبين الى هناك حتى ما طرح اسم ماسك لترشح
للرئاسه الامريكيه وهذا لا لا بعيده على
الاطلاق في عالم السياكل في امريكا كما
جاء الترام في الخارج الاوصاف
السياسيه التقليديه
بالنسبه
فالامر بعيد عنه
بس ماسكه اصلا الدعم اللي هو حاكم فلوريدا
يعني انه لو ترشح للرئاسه
[موسيقى]
الرئيس
كبرى لمن يثبت انه
يظهر شهاده ميلاد والان بالنسبه
ولد في جنوب افريقيا وبالتالي هذه المساله
همم محسوم انها مستبعده من الناحيه
القانونيه ولكن اصبح جزءا من اللعبه
السياسيه الامريكيه لانه الان يقوم
باضحالات كثيره خطيره وفضح امور تتعلق
بكبد نايتين والان قضيه التسريبات ولكن من
يطالب بان يفرج عن الوثائق الخاصه
بافسين وهذه الفضيحه الجنسيه العالميه
التي طالت العديد من
الملفات السريه في التويتر وكيف تتعامل
تويتر معها وكيف كان عنده اجنده ليبراليه
بحسب ما بيقول همم وعنده استعداد انه
يستمر في هذه اللعبه وهذا ممكن يؤثر طبعا
في اي انتخابات على العموم احنا بنشكرك
على هذه المداخله كان معنا الكاتب والباحث
السياسي بشار جرار اللي ينضم واشنطن
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]